duas pias é a melhor invenção que já
inventaram que escovar o dente vai
passou o pio e o outro vai para outro pi
pronto uma pia não funciona primeiro que
dá briga ai eu preciso escovar não mas
eu tô atrasado não mas eu tenho que
fazer não mas eu tenho não dá certo aí
entra no consenso e fala vamos fazer o
seguinte vamos escovar os dois escovar
de dois numa pia só não dá certo gente
para com isso porque um passo a pasta aí
molha ali na torneira e fica escovando
um pouquinho ali distante e o outro fica
ali escovando e usando a pia né
só que aí passa um tempinho o outro que
tava ali distante vem chegando rápido e
falar sai sai sai que eu tenho que
cuspir só que aí a pessoa que tava na
pia vai desligar a água bem na hora o
que que acontece
na mão do outro gente é nojento não não
escova direito porque tem vergonha de
escovar a língua na frente da outra
pessoa porque todo mundo que escova a
língua daquela enguiada assim quando tá
escovando né eu tenho vergonha de fazer
isso olhando para mim mesmo do espelho
às vezes eu tô escovando meu Deus meu
Deus